hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one particularly
interesting and I think for a lot of
first-time readers confusing distinction
that Aristotle will make in categories
chapter six where he's discussing
quantity is that between what we
translate as primary and secondary
senses of this category of quantity how
is it that things are of a certain
amount or measure out to to a certain
number or however we want to put it so
Aristotle is going to at this point say
something that we have to sort of you
know look back and then and then bring
these ideas in in order to make sense of
he says the things we have mentioned
alone only those things can be called in
the strictest or primary sense the
kurios in Greek sense quantities so what
has he mentioned well he's discussed
number and speech which are discrete
quantity according to him
remember speech means the length of
syllables and then we have you know
these geometric concepts like line plane
solid or body soma those are continuous
quantity
and then we have time and space which he
also treats as continuous quantity
although with a few qualifications here
and there in terms of time so those are
quantity in the primary sense of the
term that he means when we think about
it we might say speech maybe doesn't
actually fit in there when we look at
the the secondary so he goes on and he
says other things that are so-called
that are called quantities are called in
a secondary sense and and quantity you
know think of anything that we can
ascribe a number to that we can answer
the question how much or how big or how
many or how long right and he says
anything else that's being ascribed
quantity would findit fit into this this
other group of the kata some debit cost
and we can translate that as secondary
or we can translate that as derivative
strictly speaking what we're talking
about there is what is accidental
something is essentially quantity
something else happens to be called
quantity remember categories are ways of
predicating something of something else
so we call something a quantity but it's
not really itself a quantity it's a
quantity as he's going to say because of
something else and I think that looking
at the two examples that he provides
might be quite helpful so let's let's
take a look at those he says a white
object is often called large okay so or
a book take this for example
half of its white you know well maybe
more than half if we haven't both it
green as well so a green and white
object is called of a certain size we
call this for example a pocketbook
because you could you could put it in
your pocket and if we say something like
that I think that's a useful way of
talking about it because notice that
when you call something pocketbook size
you're saying that it fits into
something else it's it's in relation to
something else that it has the quantity
being pocket-sized you know in this case
maybe these books I don't know are six
inches by four inches by an inch and a
half thick I'm just guessing here right
it has a certain space and so in this
case an object is in relation to space
but it's the space that really is
according to Aristotle the quantity in
the primary sense how much space does
this thing take up how much does it
cover so he has in this case the surface
that this white object think about like
maybe a tarp that we put on the ground
the surface that it covers is large
right if we if we ask well how big how
large is that white thing you mention
the surface that it covers so in this
case you know it's not super big but
just imagine we put this thing down how
much space is covered well you know not
not quite a square foot right because
this is four inches that's six inches 24
square inches you know we can go on and
on and on right and you know we can
imagine something bigger how much how
much space is my my shirt covering less
than my tie right my tie is an object my
shirt is an object this book is an
object my body itself is an object that
is occupying a certain amount of space
but you could put something else in its
place for instance you could make a mold
of me like they do in those those
museums and make some sort of you know
dr. Sadler effigy and if it was you know
pretty close to me you would occupy more
or less the same amount of space so with
objects we're generally not quantifying
them per se we're quantifying something
else the amount of space that is being
taken up and and you might think of that
in terms
these geometric you know notions like
plain right or you might think of it in
terms of spatiality itself what about
things that exist in time here's where
we might actually want to rethink speech
a little bit although Aristotle doesn't
at this point he uses the example of an
action right a praxis he also uses
another example closely related to that
which is of a process of change kinases
and he says here we go
an action or process is called long
since the time that it occupies is long
so it's dependent on something other
than itself on time so if we go on and
we look at what he says about this he
says somebody asks you how long was that
action what what number would you assign
to that action well you're assigning
something whether in seconds or years or
minutes or whatever measure that you
want moons right whatever it is that
you're using as a point of comparison
whatever time terms those are time and
the action exists in a certain amount of
time this is why you know when it comes
down to it we might want to assimilate
speech we might want to put speech over
here on this side and say that speech
actually exists
in relation to time long and short you
know might be a certain amount of time
and half that amount of time if we're
talking about you know the long and
short syllables that are used in Greek
words put that aside for the moment
let's let's see what else
Aristotle saying here says the name
quantity cannot be given to such things
as of their own right it doesn't mean
that we can't say that they are
quantities or that they have a certain
number but it means that they don't have
that in and of themselves they are not
primary it's just
accidental that they so happen to be
that way and this requires a little
transformation in how we typically think
of these things we often think of an
action as of a certain length in time
right but it's really the time that
we're referring to we think of objects
as being of a certain magnitude when
really it's the amount of space that
they're occupying that that matters he
goes on and he says the things then
referred to alone in themselves cans can
be strictly called quantities these
things right
other things thus designated only they
claim to that name if at all in a
secondary sense in a derivative fashion
and not from their intrinsic nature so
again just to reinforce and to bring
this to a close it's not to say that
things over here don't have quantity at
all it's just not as essential to what
they are as it is to things over here
which which are quantities or are ways
for quantity to be you might say or what
it is that quantity can be quantity of
now you notice there's one that doesn't
get talked about at all here and that's
number except insofar as we're relating
it to time or to space